foreign
[Music]
let's get this show on the road or 1500
I will say that the last couple of games
been a while since we've had so
yesterday we had a game
which kind of dragged on for a while but
I really enjoyed our discussion
afterward on you know various important
Concepts that occurred so hopefully
you've been enjoying it so far
um on we go to another game
we are
1517 so things really kind of heating up
and getting interesting I think we'll
have the black pieces let's roll the
cameras
and get the show on the road
all right no we have the white pieces
and we're playing a 1600 so very decent
player
and here we go E4 C6 nice we're gonna
get another fantasy variation which
we've been exploring quite a bit uh I
think we've already had two games in the
fantasy and so we've explored quite a
bit of theory already and you know just
to reiterate the
philosophy of the speed run the higher
rated we get the more in the more deeply
we're going to examine the openings in
the games that we play because the more
Theory we're going to get from our
opponents
D takes C4 we faced this move before and
in the previous game I think our
opponent played a pretty big mistake
Knight F6 and here we go again this guy
repeats the same exact line you might
remember that the only way to justify
this line is to play the move E5 it's
critical for black to play E5 otherwise
you're essentially getting a a bad
version of an alkyne which is already a
pretty bad opening to begin with so I'll
be impressed if people can remember the
previous game this was maybe five or six
games ago it's up on YouTube if you're
watching this on YouTube and you don't
know what I'm talking about you can
pause and find the previous game in the
caracon and you can watch that video
first we're gonna basically repeat
everything that we did in that game
and I don't remember exactly what we did
but I do remember that the move in this
position of course is E5 much like in
the alkyne and this is a very awkward
version of an alkyne because the pawn on
C6 belongs on C5 in order to break down
White Center so that's a loss of a Tempo
already and and second of all the
semi-openf file is in White's favor this
is very important to understand you
might look at this and say isn't our
King weak here and to that I say well
think of it in the long run after we
complete our King side development and
we Castle our Rook on F1 is going to be
aiming at F7 so there's a high
probability that we win this game with a
direct assault on the F7 Pawn
so here we have uh a a basically a
choice of two approaches to repeat what
I was mentioning in the previous game we
can play this develop mentally we can
play Knight F3 and Bishop B2 or whatnot
and then Castle short but the more
ambitious way to play this is to occupy
more of the center to chase the Knight
away from D5 much like we do in the
alkyne and we want to play principal
chess let's send this Knight back to
Timbuk2 with the move C4
and this is indeed what we did
previously now in that previous game I'm
pretty sure that our opponent played
Knight to C7 so this is the first
substantive deviation Knight B6 is a
somewhat more logical move because the
Knight maintains contact with the C4
Pawn
and now we obviously need to develop our
pieces in order to support our large
Center in order to make sure that the
center doesn't fall apart so in what
order do we develop our pieces
um another point that I made in the
previous game is that we shouldn't
necessarily Rush the move Knight F3
because Knight F3 allows black to
develop the bishop to G4 is that pin the
end of the world absolutely not but a
smarter way to develop here is to try to
wait it out wait for black to play
Bishop F5 and then develop the Knight to
F3 because the bishop on F5 is clearly
inferior to an annoying Bishop on G4 so
we start with the most flexible
developing Moves In this case those
moves I think are Knight to C3 and then
Bishop to E3 we don't want to go Bishop
to D3 because that hangs the pawn on D4
so if we do develop the bishop we'd
probably develop it to E2 or we can play
Bishop to E3 supporting the pawn and
then Bishop to D3 but all of this should
be taken to the grain of salt we need to
wait for black to develop for us to
decide there we go Bishop F5 is on the
board and now we can very comfortably
develop the Knight to F3 because it's
not worth for black to waste another
Tempo to reposition the bishop we'd be
happy to see that so hopefully you can
understand the logic
let's go with Knight F3
and I'm assuming black is going to go E6
and you should temper your expectations
this is an important point about
punishing bad openings normally when a
mistake is made along the lines of
Knight F6 you shouldn't fall into the
Trap of assuming that you're suddenly
winning or that you should expect to
have a winning position in 10 moves
that's not how chess works I would
estimate the evaluation to be maybe plus
one so you know white has a clear
Advantage here but we should not be
looking for a knockout blow because
you're not going to find one and that's
only going to lead you down a very
dangerous path where you're likely to to
overextend yourself
so the next dilemma is which Bishop we
should develop I think we should focus
on our King side because I want to get
the king out of the center as quickly as
possible and I also want to reap the
benefit of the f file as quickly as
possible so that leads us to the light
squared Bishop now where should we go
well along the same lines what's
stopping us from benefiting from the
file the bishop on F5 is kind of an
annoying roadblock so I don't see any
reason for us not to play the move
Bishop D3 we're happy with the trade of
of light skirt Bishops it's not our
light squared Bishop isn't necessary for
the attack and once we get rid of the
Bishops we unfetter the f-file
and we're happy very important Point
whenever you have a big Center like this
you always have to make sure that your
opponent can't cut into the center with
their pawns a move like C5 can be
incredibly nasty and if black can get
this Pawn on D4 off the board White
Center is likely to collapse so
importantly and we talked about this in
the previous game as well C5 can be met
with the move D5 if you count the
Defenders we have one two Defenders on
that square and two attackers so so
we're chilling but we should make a
mental note to ourselves on every move
literally to just double check to make
sure that C5 can still be met with D5
Bishop E7 okay we obviously Castle
we've completed our kingside development
and I assume our opponent is also going
to Castle
so here we have an interesting very
interesting moment actually because I
think the majority of you as you're
looking at the position your instinct is
probably to play Bishop E3 here or maybe
some of you want Bishop F4 which I don't
like because it blocks the f file
maybe some of you are tempted by C5 C5
uh is a very bad move positionally
because it gives black gifts black a
monster Outpost in the center on D5 we
there's no need to play C5 here
uh perhaps some of you are contemplating
a move like B3 to solidify the pawn but
I have far more violent thoughts on my
mind when I look at this position I
actually have a feeling that we can go
directly for checkmate here we can
exploit the fact that black hasn't even
completed his Queen side development and
we can try to pounce before black even
knows what hit him now what does it mean
to pounce in this position right we
can't play Knight G5 this is a move that
all of you should see and you should
understand its General value if we can
get Knight G5 that's a huge made threat
and the great thing about this
particular type of maid threat is that
black can't defend with H6 that defends
the pawn but not the square so if we can
force black to make a tremendously
weakening move like this we'll already
be you know three steps to delivering
Checkmate so can we prepare the move
Knight G5 while building more Harmony
among our pieces yes we can and as many
of you are indicating I am very tempted
by the move 94.
and I'm going to think about this for
Just Another Second
the thing is after 94 obviously black
and play H6 and prevent Knight G5 so the
question is is it worth inducing that
move or
should we hold our horses and play
positionally with Bishop E3 both
approaches are entirely possible
so I'm going to take 30 seconds just to
make that decision
because there is a subtle but not
insignificant downside to playing Knight
E4 and I know I'm talking a lot in this
example in this in this position but
it's an important position to really
understand what's going on the downside
of 94 is that after H6 we made a mental
note to ourselves what the debt notes
say to check C5 on every move notice
that after we move the Knight on away
from C3 we will no longer be able to
meet C5 with D5 because now the D5
square has insufficient Defenders but I
saw one step ahead we are going to play
94 because after H6 I think I've spotted
a really cute move a move that solves
all of our problems in the center and
puts you know puts the heat on all sides
of the board
so we're gonna wait for black to play H6
because that's far from Force black
could try C5 straight away
and that will lead us to a direct
tactical skirmish
so we'll see what our opponent chooses
it's entirely possible that Knight E4 is
a mistake it's entirely possible that
you know I'm playing this
in a slightly overzealous manner but I
really don't think so this just has to
work all of the ingredients are in place
our Center is amazing Our Queen is
aiming at H7 94 flows naturally from the
position
okay so I think our opponent is deciding
between H6 maybe he's thinking G6 no
he's not he's ignoring he's calling my
bluff he's saying come at me brah and to
that I say yes I will
so here we go now here we go can mean
two different things this is actually a
very important moment most of you are
obviously thinking let's go Knight eg5
right what would be the point of
bringing the other Knight to G5 well
actually we're gonna play Knight F to G5
why Knight F to G5 still creates a maid
threat if you look carefully the main
threat is Knight F6 check discovered
check essentially and then Queen takes
H7 mate and the beautiful thing about
Knight fg5 is that it's a more efficient
division of labor than bringing the
other Knight to G5 if you think about it
after sorry after Knight E to G5 black
plays G6 and we have a slightly awkward
situation where the Knight on F3 is
blocking the queen from moving to H3
it's blocking The Rook from attacking F7
meanwhile if we bring the other Knight
to G5 and get black to take it not only
do we remove a very important Defender
but also after Knight takes G5 Our Queen
is free to roam about the third rank
it's just a far more harmonious position
hopefully that logic also makes sense we
go Knight fg5
far more effective and if black is not
careful obviously this game could end in
Checkmate on the next move
now what's interesting is that after
Bishop takes G5
uh this might blow your mind but I think
the best move there is actually Bishop
takes G5 because I've noticed a
essentially a mating pattern that I
think leads to immediate victory
and the way that I see this is just that
I know I know the pattern that's all
there is to it and if our opponent takes
the Knight then I'll be able to show you
the pattern
yeah a lot of you are indicating it in
chat there is this idea of sacking the
Knight on F6 and essentially delivering
a version of the lobster pincer made
with you know a piece on F6 and then a
piece on H6 everybody should know what
I'm talking about you know when you have
a Pawn on F6 and a queen on H6 and mate
on G7 is Unstoppable it's essentially a
version of that made along the dark
squares
and if he doesn't do it I'll show it
after the game
so the most resilient move for black
here is undoubtedly G6
and in response to G6 you should kind of
be asking yourself what catches your eye
because there's a couple of very
attempting moves there I still haven't
decided yet
so I'm going to do a little thinking on
that front
G6 is played very very nicely done by
our opponent now we need to be careful
here because notice that the D4 Pawn is
only defended once now we can sacrifice
that pawn and you should also understand
that Queen takes D4 check is really not
the end of the world we can block that
check with Bishop E3 we can even step
aside with our King so we shouldn't
reject a move just because it gives away
the pawn but we should be aware of it so
I think we have basically two candidate
moves two candidate moves there is the
tempting move Knight F6 check which
virtually compels black to take on F6
and then we have a total Monopoly over
the dark squares on the king side and
total Monopoly over a set of squares is
an incredibly valuable resource that you
can directly transform into Checkmate
and we'll discuss that more after the
game the second candidate move the
second candidate move is Queen to H3
note that after Queen takes D4 check
Bishop should be three that's a double
attack we threatened the queen and we
threatened Checkmate so Queen H3 forces
black to go H5 and that's another
massive massive weakening so Queen H3
makes a lot of sense but we need a
follow-up after H5
and it's not that easy to find one it's
not that easy to break through Black's
defenses on the king's side
a lot of you are saying G4 but that's
slow and then black takes on D4 and
takes on E5 and your Center collapses
I'm far from convinced that that leads
to a clean checkmate I'm far from
convinced that that leads to a clean
checkmate
so from that perspective
I'm tempted by the appearance of Knight
F6 check let me think about this for a
couple more moments I'm gonna try to be
clinical here
there there
I have a very interesting idea
but I'm again I'm working it out I'm
working it out
to calculate it
yeah there's all sorts of sacrifices
there but nothing that's quite as
convincing
as I would like
for it to be
because I would like for it to be
but there's one variation of trying to
work it out it's it's complicated
it's complicated
so I'm leaning towards just going Knight
F6 check
I'm leaning towards going Knight F6
check Bishop takes F6 Rook takes F6 and
basically saying
listen I've got you know a long-term
attack on the king side I'm going to
secure my advantages I'm going to bank
it and then we're going to try to look
for The Knockout blow let's go Knight F6
check let's show some restraint I did
not see a forced win after queen h3h5
I'm sure the engine will but given our
time situation I think the Practical
option uh the Practical choice is to
play a lower risk move that we know is
going to yield long-term attacking
chances
now if Bishop takes F6
and by the way those anytime I am
recovering from a cold so uh you know I
apologize for my voice if Bishop takes
F6 it's tempting I know to take with the
pawn but the downside of taking with the
pawn the huge downside is that you're
blocking the f-file and the f-file is
one of the main Avenues of attack in
fact our entire opening strategy
revolves around attacking down the
f-file so the only reason you would take
with the pawn is if you could guarantee
is if you could guarantee that you could
land the queen on H6 that is the lobster
pincer made can you make that guarantee
well not really because after ef6 wait a
second
there's Knight takes H7 after ef6 so I
actually wouldn't rule it out
oh this changes a lot
wait a moment
no that changes everything so here's
what I saw after e takes F6 we have a
massive threat we have the threat of
playing Knight takes H7
and after King takes H7 we swing the
queen from H3 to H6 with the lobster
pincer made that we've been talking
about
so I actually think e-takes F6 is worth
playing
of course my initial idea was to play
Rook takes F6 and we'll explore that
after the game I'm not convinced that
I'm playing in the best possible way but
I really really hope that we'll get a
chance to to carry out this maneuver
this idea
now another very important point a lot
of you are probably wondering well what
about a move like H6 here or what about
a move like H5 setting up the defensive
Poncho what well then you should spot a
tactic right the queen is aiming at G6
the pawn on F7 is overloaded we play
Knight takes E6 classic deflection and
if F takes C6 then Queen takes G6 queen
queen G7 is Checkmate all right
everybody should see that
uh and this is if if black pushes the H
Pawn any time a pawn is pushed other
pawns become weaker other squares become
weaker you should ingrain that in your
mind especially when you've got
situations that are highly charged from
a tactical standpoint and you know this
position is right you know there's
mating ideas you know there's tactics so
you have to put your your Tactical hat
on so to speak
yeah black is probably lost but I have a
feeling that if if our opponent finds an
accurate defensive move I don't know
which one but I don't think the game is
totally over
but the story of this position is not
only the weakness of Black's King but
the the inactivity as somebody in the
chat is pointing out of the knights you
just cannot play a successful middle
game with both of your minor pieces
essentially out of commission for good
not only are they not participating in
the defense they're not even
participating in a counter-attack
they're just sort of sitting there
and and we have for that reason a a
massive superiority on the other side of
the board
so there is a cute move Knight to C5
okay there we go H5 this has worked like
a charm Knight takes E6 okay
just double checking because there is
there is one complicating move
but it doesn't work we play Knight takes
C6 deflection overloading if fe6 this is
made in two
and the F Pawn decides the game
now of course black needs to move the
queen but then we take our rook and we
Bank the material advantage but then we
keep attacking and I'll make this point
once we get to that position but a lot
of people what tends to happen in these
situations is that you you grab the
material and then you say the game is
over I can just start simplifying no
right you it being up material is even
more of a reason to play for checkmate
okay so after Knight takes f8 we're not
just going to try to trade queens and
cower and some endgame we're just gonna
step on the gas pedal and try to finish
the game off
okay Queen to D6
Queen to D6
interesting stuff
now what's hilarious
what's hilarious is that we don't
necessarily have to play Knight takes f8
there are some Alternatives but given
the time situation we're not even going
to toy with them we're gonna go Knight
fate
and we are going to claim our material
advantage okay so of course you should
point you should notice that C5
is a false friend because black has
Knight takes C5 and the queen is
unprotected right always notice these
x-rays between pieces
so
what is the ideal scenario the ideal
scenario is for us to get our Queen to
H6 so from that perspective we we get
the idea of playing Queen to E3
but the issue with Queen E3 well the
good thing about Queen E3 is that it
also reinforces the threat of C5 so it's
actually a double attack but after Queen
E3 black has an annoying defensive move
Queen E3 notice that black has Knight
back to D7 attacking the F6 Pawn
okay if we play Queen H6 black is in
time to eliminate the pawn from F6 and
black survives so amazingly Queen E3
Knight D7 we have to find a response
there
and I'm thinking about one
but I don't yet see something
that I'm totally happy with there yeah
we can play C5 first Knight takes C5 and
then Queen E3 but then the other Knight
drops back to D7 and it creates the same
effect we cannot afford to lose this
Pawn that greatly complicates uh the
winning process so let's kind of wipe
the Slate clean and let's forget for a
second about playing for immediate
Checkmate instead let's focus on
building up some more fundamentals we
need a little bit more beef we need to
bring all the toys to the nursery party
and I think I see a very nice way of
doing that the fundamental problem is
that we don't have enough pieces
developed right we're struggling because
we're offloading all of the work just to
The Rook our entire Queen side is you
know like a jar of cookies yet to be
open we have all of this good stuff that
can come out let's bring it out now
what's the nicest way to bring it out
the nicest way to bring it out I think
is not Bishop H6 because we want to
leave that Square open for the queen
but using a little bit of tactics we can
develop the bishop to another square
with Tempo very good I'm impressed with
how many people are pointing this out am
I not blundering the pawn on F6 that's
what our opponent is wondering well the
f-file decides the game we have the
X-ray and the Queen the X-ray is a
precursor to a discovered attack what
can we attack we can't check the king
because it's on a light square if the
King was on h8 we would have played
Bishop E5 with the pin but obviously we
have Bishop to H6 winning a second
exchange and that essentially decides
the game
okay maybe I over explain that but moves
like Bishop F4 are you know really often
the difference between winning the game
in five more moves and you know winning
the game in 50 moves or maybe not
winning the game at all you know
allowing your opponent to stick around
and if you don't have a lot of time it's
especially uh important to find these
moves and and play them accurately
all right we take the Rook
now again we still should not rest on
our Laurels we definitely should not aim
for a queen trade here we should
continue playing for mate okay so we
still can't really go C5 because of
Knight takes C5 all right so that's uh
important to notice
so as many of you are pointing out we
should bring the Rook into the game
where should we put it well I love the
look of Rook ae1 because that's an open
file you could also make a case for Rook
a to D1 because that reinforces the
threat of C5 but if we want to play this
clinically then we should definitely go
Rook a to E1
no no sacks on F7 none of that nonsense
unless you've calculated to checkmate
all right you got to be disciplined
kudos to our opponent he's trying trying
everything now we don't take the Knight
that wonders the queen we move the queen
where do we go well what's the most
natural Square why did we put the Rook
on E1 well we did that in order to be
able to infiltrate down the e-file
so we have Queen F3 but that allows
Queen takes D4 check sloppy the move is
Queen E3 using more tactics 96 we have
the X-ray on the king
that means the F7 Pawn is immobile
and we have of course the move C5 as an
option but if we want to play a little
bit more elegantly
Queen takes C6 is pretty
and that's it I think that's one too
many pieces
Queen takes D4 check is nothing to be
afraid of as long as black cannot
dislodge The Rook which of course he
cannot the game is over
right and and this is why
good beginner tactics books emphasize
themes first and foremost you have to
learn the Tactical ingredients of each
position
if you solve blindly without knowing the
underlying Concepts then it's hard to
generalize them right and this is also
an illustration of the importance of
making observations observations before
you see the tactic right I noticed this
a long time ago the moment King appeared
on f8 I made a mental note to myself
okay the F7 Pawn essentially it's as if
it is it isn't there right it's not
actually defending either of these
squares and that's how you see stuff
like Queen takes C6 quickly
um let's have a look pretty
straightforward game
and
another successful fantasy variation so
I won't repeat what I said in the
previous uh caracon game again if you
haven't seen that video or you want a
refresher on what we discussed there
pause the video take a look at that
other video and in that video I pretty
extensively went over the move E5 I gave
you a pretty extensive overview the move
here for white is Knight F3 and
essentially here black has three three
main moves there's Bishop G4 which is
most popular and the best move there's e
takes D4 which is now considered very
dubious there's Bishop to E6 which is
also very dubious
and uh you can take a look at that video
for the theoretical overview what I'll
say in this uh video to advance our
knowledge of the fantasy is that apart
from D takes E4 there are three or four
very reputable alternatives
um and the one that most grand Masters
play and that I faced most often online
at my level is this move E6 which you
could almost argue transposes the game
into a version of the French with the
inclusion of the move C6 and F3 but that
actually really changes the the nature
of the position
and the funny thing here is that after
the correct move Knight C3 if black
plays Knight F6 who can tell me how you
can actually transpose directly into a
variation of the French which is often
not to the liking of a Karo Khan player
because most cargo players don't play
the French very good you can play E5
Knight ft7 F4 and after a C5 black is
nothing better Knight F3 Knight C6
you've transposed directly into a main
variation of the classical French which
occurs after e460 45 Knight C3 Knight F6
this is the classical variation the win
hour is Bishop B4 but Knight F6 is also
very reputable and White's main line
here is to play F4 C5 and after Knight
F3 Knight C6 Bishop B3 you get literally
the same position so most Karo Khan
players here actually go win our style
with Bishop to B4
with Bishop to B4
and we had a game here uh as well in in
the previous speeder when we faced a
slightly questionable opponent uh the
move here for white
is let me actually remember
so so the main line I think is Bishop to
F4 but that's not what I recommend I
recommend the move A3 which is actually
a fascinating Pawn sacrifice
and the reason this is a sacrifice that
black and play Bishop C3 and then D
takes E4 and you can't take back because
of the nasty check on H4 I'll be super
impressed if somebody in the chat can
remember what the move here is for white
we had this position I lost that game
but I was much better out of the opening
all right mombon Discord deserves a sub
all of you remember it's Knight H3
honestly amazing to see how many people
pay attention
Knight H3 is the move that you literally
just have to know it's it's hard to
figure this move out
uh and the idea is to develop the Knight
and uh to threaten the move F take C4
because then Queen H4 can be met with
the move Knight back to F2
so you can take a look at that game as
well I think that's the beauty of the
speeder run right our knowledge it
builds up on each other that's why you
should really try to watch the videos in
sequence so that's one line and a line
that I have not talked about at all but
that scares a lot of people away from
playing the fantasy thank you Kavita for
gifting to Mom on Discord is a move that
first was pioneered by bad or jababa one
of the top Karo Khan experts and that's
Queen to B6
putting immediate pressure on the D4
Pawn okay and
in the context of this video I will
limit myself uh just to one variation
I'm sure we're going to get the Karo
Khan again once we're 18 or 1900 I'm
going to show you kind of the full
Theory after Knight C3 so here Black's
best move is again to play E6
but a very scary move that trips a lot
of people up is actually E5
and the idea of E5 is very
straightforward right you're forcing D
takes E5 and you're bringing the bishop
out to C5 and Visually it's terrifying
because there's a check on F2 and the
Knight on G1 is literally hanging so you
can't just go e takes D5 you blunder the
Knight on G1
so does anybody know what the move here
is for white there is a very important
move and if you remember this move
there's no problems here white is better
Knight A4 is absolutely right any time
you have a queen on B6 and a bishop on
C5 you have to remember this idea of
sticking the Knight on the rim
and the point is that okay there's two
moves there's Queen A5 check but Bishop
F2 is what could look terrifying do not
go King D2 and get checkmated make sure
that E3 is still protected but this if
you look carefully forces black to
acquiesce to the queen trade the queen
has to keep contact with the bishop so
black has to go Queen D4
and now you trade Queens I've played
this with black actually quite a few
times and here it's important to realize
that you actually want to keep the E5
Pawn protected so the best move is just
to go F4 and yes you give back the pawn
but after Bishop E3 eliminating Black's
strongest piece black and throw in a
check big deal you just go King F2 and
When the Smoke Clears white is clearly
better because black is struggling to
keep the spawn protected the Knight can
jump into C5 and you've just got a big
big Pawn majority on the king side uh
that you can push forward with H3 and G4
and you can keep analyzing this on your
own if you wanna deepen your knowledge
but that's basically all you have to
know if you're under 2200.
uh so the second move here is Queen A5
check and now the key detail is C3
remember this concept because you're
opening up a defense on the queen this
is a very very common technique in a lot
of different openings a lot of different
openings in the French you actually get
a very similar idea
very similar idea let me remember in
which line so I think it's in the Knight
C3 line that there's a variation of the
French the classical lines so very
similar to the fantasy
where you get yeah you get the main line
and then
let me remember how oh yeah so it's it's
Queen B6 and here the traditional move
is Knight to A4 same concept Queen A5
Chuck are we losing the Knight do we
need to go back no we play C3 and the
fascinating thing is that after C takes
D4 white has a brilliant intermediate
move does anybody know what it is
it's B4
counter-attacking the queen and forcing
it back there is a sack on B4 but that's
not very good
and then you take back on D4
what is the purpose of this move why not
Knight takes D4 because that excuse me
then you get burned for putting the
Knight on A4 black takes it and black
goes B5 and the Knight is unfortunately
trapped on A4
so again and again these concepts are
generalizable to a lot of different
openings even if you're a D4 player
watching the speed run you can take a
lot of these ideas and you can apply
them in most cases to the openings that
you play
so once again after e5de Bishop C5
Knight a4.85 C3 black can take on G1 but
crucially if black plays B5 the contact
between the queen and the C5 square has
been severed so you have this Escape
score for your knight white is
considered to be clearly better here
according to opening theory if D takes
C4 then you can bring your queen up to
D4 and centralize it and you've got a
big initiative
so that's what I'll limit myself to in
terms of opening remarks for this game
now let's get to the actual game
continuation de and Knight F6
and again I won't beat a dead horse here
we've already discussed in the previous
game why this type of line is bad for
black it's an inferior version of an
alkyne which is already a dubious
opening
and after Knight B6 important detail
right we delay Knight F3 we wait for
black to bring the bishop out and only
then do we develop the Knight to F3
so for the time being both sides I think
are playing Pretty logically Bishop D3
trade on D3 it's already almost plus two
according to the engine just so you know
how bad a position like this is
and again C5 is met with D5 this is
important Bishop B7 castles castles and
here we decided on a very ambitious
approach 94
and I think the big question here
uh would have been what is our move
against H6
and what I was planning here
from my perspective is a slow well not a
slow move I had in mind a very
interesting move that might actually
turn out to be slightly overzealous but
the engine does like it
and that's the move Knight to D6 wow and
perturb you basically got it
you basically got it but starting with
C5 is good but far more inflexible right
you only want to play C5 if you
absolutely need to and Knight D6 is
working tactically because if black
takes twice then you go C5 with a fork
and this is just incredibly unpleasant
we can support the pawn with C5 black
can barely breathe here
I mean this is just a terrible position
but what's interesting is that the
engine also gives uh a very nice
attacking option you can go G4 uh using
this Pawn as a hook you can just you
know bring this Pawn up to G5 and this
is pretty devastating as well
C5 you don't care just go G5 close your
eyes and attack
and all black can do is take the pawn
but who cares about the center if you're
checkmating your opponent the priorities
have shifted and this is an important
General point that I want to make a lot
of people they
you know make sure that you don't think
of you have to think of everything in
relative terms what was important a
couple of moves ago might be totally
insignificant now a couple of moves ago
we didn't have our attack going yet so
it was crucial for us to keep our Center
intact once we've decided that we're
going for mate that becomes the only
important thing we don't care about our
Center anymore as long as we are able to
keep essentially Black's Queen at Bay
we're able to prevent the queen trade
which we are because the Knight defends
the pawn now
we're we're aiming squarely for
checkmate we don't care about the
Integrity of our Center and Hereafter G
takes H6 G6 Knight F G5 I mean just look
at this look at this this is totally
devastating Knight C6 and now the engine
gives the cute move Queen to G3 X rang
the G6 Pawn
and if black makes a random move Knight
takes F7 is game over Red Rover because
Queen takes G6 and notice the pawn on H6
fulfills a defensive role stopping Rook
G7 otherwise black would be winning
so multiple options here to achieve a
decisive Advantage very aggressive with
G4 or positional with Knight T6 or even
just Rook D1 nothing wrong with the
Soviet School of Chess approach again
prophylaxis against C5 you're totally
overwhelming here
so lots of options our opponent decided
on Knight A6 and here Knight fg5 is
essentially devastating
so if black had taken with the bishop
just to reiterate what I was saying
Bishop takes G5 here I think might be
even more convincing than Knight takes
G5
because after black moves the queen we
have the simple mating pattern Knight F6
check and then Bishop takes F6 and just
look at Black's king queen G3 pre-move
Rook F4 Rook G4 whatever you want to do
this is utterly and completely
devastating
the one thing that you want to avoid
here black can move the Rook away let's
say to d8 if black moves The Rook to E8
then you check me in on G7 so a quick
piece of advice if you're on the
defending side in these types of
situations and you're trying to move the
Rook away to give your king as much
breathing room as possible you often
want to move the Rook as far away as
possible but often that is actually d8
because if you move the Rook to B8
what's fascinating about this we're
going to use the method of comparison
here we're going to compare two
different lines and you're immediately
going to see why one is better here we
drive the king out into the center
and here is where we want to compare two
positions after King C8 Queen E8 is
checkmate but imagine that The Rook was
on d8 here after King C8 The Rook
actually defends the E8 Square so the
best compromise move is Rook f8 to d8
and as white you want to demonstrate
patience here is there any hurry for us
to give a check on G3 absolutely not
because if the king runs on its own
volition we can grab the pawn on H7
so we can use the opportunity to
essentially tighten the screws of attack
and just bring as many pieces into the
attack as possible now what's the most
straightforward way of doing that don't
block the Queen's access to G3 though
so what's a nice way to bring another
piece into the attack it's The Rook lift
and not just a rook lift we're preparing
to double our Rooks on the file and I'm
giving you the engine line here because
it's destructive
okay got Fate
and just for kf1
King E8 and now we can leisurely take
the pawn why are we taking the pawn now
to prevent the king from running any
further
because now if the king runs any further
we just adopt the approach of taking all
of Black's material Queen F7 and just
Bishop takes d8 literally simple chess
obviously if Queen takes d8 then we take
and go Rook f8
with win and if Queen takes F7 then in
this position we give a check
and then we give another check
and we force the Knight back to D7
and we take the free rook on Aid is that
the only winning line absolutely not in
fact the engine which is kind of evil
claims that the most clinical move is
Knight takes G5 and now a really sexy
move I love this next move I'll give you
a chance to find it
what do I love about it well my favorite
types of attacking moves are actually
retreating moves
so you might think that the Knight is
the strongest piece but what's the best
Square for the night if you could lift
the Knight and put it on any Square on
the board what would it be
well it would not be G5 it would be the
F6 Square the move is Knight back to E4
threatening the infiltration of Knight
F6 black is forced to play Knight t7
and now we shift the queen over to H3
and the other great thing about moving
the Knight away is that we've opened up
the pathway for the bishop now to
infiltrate G5 or for the queen to step
into H6
why is it important for the queen to
step into H6 because if you play Knight
G5 immediately you allow H5 so here the
accurate move is either Queen H6 or
Bishop to G5 the queen moves and then we
can literally do anything we want I like
the look of Queen H6
followed by Knight F6 with checkmate
so these details
again is stuff that you can remember
right oh this is an interesting idea let
me look for retreating moves and let me
not be satisfied by pieces that look
good on the surface let me try to find
the best squares for them
so hopefully you found these lines to be
somewhat Illuminating in the game our
opponent plays the other move which is
G6 of course H6 we have the discovery on
F6 followed by Checkmate on H7
so after G6 we had another dilemma and
most of you were kind of cheering for
Queen H3 but after Queen h3h5 I did not
see a follow-up
what did I spend time calculating you
might ask the move that I was trying to
assess is actually not a good move at
all I spent a little bit trying to
figure out Rook takes F7
which is a classic idea and I think the
official name for this is demolition the
way this is referred to in uh books on
tactics like demolition of of the
opponent's punt Pawn structure or of the
King's Pawn cover where you basically
sack a little bit of material and you
completely obliterate the pawnshell the
problem is that you leave your back rank
exposed and the underlying problem is
that we haven't developed our Queen side
so after Rook F7 Queen E6 our old friend
comes back to haunt us Queen takes D4
check and white loses King H1 Queen D1
is checkmate
so that's totally unnecessary Knight
takes F7 is similarly crappy because if
Queen takes D4 check and the Knight on
e4 hangs with a total mess with a total
mess
but for every one of these examples
where
you know
where where Rook takes F7 doesn't work I
can probably find you an example where
this exact idea works perfectly right so
all of this doesn't work only because
the uh Pawn on D4 is so vulnerable let
me see if I can run a quick search
and find an example of an idea like this
working
so let me see I'm going to run a quick
search I probably won't but uh
it's worth a shot
let's take a look as this search is
going
where were we we were talking about
Knight fg5 G6 and now I was explaining
why uh I didn't want to go Queen H3 yeah
the reason is that this leaves the D4
Pawn very exposed and C4 is also hanging
so if we play Bishop B3 suddenly Black's
back in the game you know Knight takes
C4 and unless you can figure out a
concrete uh win on the king side it's
just not worth abandoning uh abandoning
the center quite this early
okay
so
oh here's a very nice game actually
actually this is a pretty sexy game so
uh it's it's not a famous game it's just
a game from the 90s it's white to play
in this position
and adelang finds a way to capitalize on
the same theme with two different
tactical ideas
so white clearly has an attack here how
do I know that well look at the queen
there's an open H file and there's a
potential mating Square on H7 I call
this thinking in terms of squares
what you do is you identify potential
mating squares long before you actually
see how you can exploit them and that
actually often helps you figure out the
tactic so if you think about it the H7
square is a potential meaning Square so
you start thinking can I go Bishop takes
G6 well the answer is no it's way
premature right FG not entirely
convincing can I go Rook F7 also no
because after Rook F7 you're not quite
breaking through you need a slightly
more subtle way to break through the
pawn structure and such a subtle way
exists it's 96 very nice 96.
and if F take C6
then we have a very important
intermediate step we need to eliminate
the Knight
Bishop takes C5 Bishop takes G6 and even
though it's not a check
Checkmate on H7 is literally Unstoppable
yeah black has a bunch of checks but
none of them do anything
so hopefully that makes sense black
gives a check on V6 here
white calmly steps away and now Watch
What Happens black plays BC
so black is trying to mix things up on
the queen side and distract white now a
brilliant retreating move
the night for me six drops back to G5
suddenly it's an attacker again
blackstroke moves away from d8 and now
the reason that I'm showing you this
game white to play and win most
efficiently everything is winning even
Bishop takes E5 but I love the way that
white finished this game off Rook takes
F7 here's an example of this idea
working breaking through the pawn chain
and now bang bang
and black resigned because Queen takes
C7 is a beautiful mate
so there you have it right an example of
of Rook takes F7 working in a different
set of circumstances
which is which should be the centerpiece
of your attitude and mentality in chess
something doesn't work in one position
doesn't mean the whole idea is wrong
it's because of the specific
circumstances of the game but hopefully
you enjoyed that little illustration
let's go back to the game
so any questions about this position
after Queen H5 Queen h3h5 were there any
attempts that people wanted to test out
uh that that were tempting you
so snipey snob says yes oh G4 so I
mentioned this during the game the
reason G4 is ineffective or not as
effective as it may appear
has to do I think with Bishop takes G5
for starters the idea is that after
Bishop takes G5 Queen takes D4 check the
Knight is suddenly undefended and if you
have to go here I mean this is yucky
you've given up your Center you don't
have anything to show for it and if you
play Knight takes G5 then after Queen
takes D4 black is threatening a forced
Queen trade and white is no longer
better white is no longer better Queen
takes G4 and
your attack is evaporated so I'm
impressed that people know this idea of
playing G4 but again you have to keep
your Center uh under reps but for that
reason we decided to cash in with Knight
F6 checked and he takes F6 and I think
here was perhaps the last opportunity
for black to prolong the game in the
game H5 Knight takes C6 leads to
immediate victory for white according to
the engine the only defensive move here
and it doesn't even really defend was E5
E5 but after E5 we can proceed with our
plan of Knight takes H7
we can proceed with our plan and the
idea is King H7 Queen H3 and queen H6
totally meaningless check and black is
checkmated on G7 this is the lobster pin
sir we've got a piece on F6 and a piece
on H6 and made is Unstoppable
now when you've got this construction
and I'm sure I'll talk about this more
in other games what do you have to be
very careful about you have to be very
careful that black cannot use a knight
to protect the G7 Square people often
forget that this can be defended against
with a knight from E6 or E8 and again
what kills black is the lack of
proximity of the knights to the king
side the knights neither night has the
option of reaching E6 here but if black
snide was on C7 this would not have
worked because of 96. because of 96.
okay so often when you're dealing with
uh situations that involve a lobster
pincer mate you have to make sure that
you've covered covered the E6 Square
and I actually have a super cool
illustration of that
from a
um
from a high level Grand Master game let
me see if I can find it before we move
on
here you go
I might have shown this once on stream
before but I don't think most people
will be familiar with it it's a crazy
position
samboya against Wei
now what's going on in a position like
this
very often I think people get
overwhelmed because you feel like you're
getting carried away by the current and
you don't know where to start well you
should start somewhere and you should
usually start just by asking yourself if
there are any tempting moves that kind
of call your attention well first you
should start with a material count you
know what's the material count well
material is actually believe it or not
kind of equal black is up two pawns
that's all there is to it neither side
is up any pieces
so first thing I'll point out
is that taking the Rook is not effective
because
okay black takes back and yeah black has
two pawns for the exchange and without a
knight it's going to be very very
difficult for us to continue our attack
white should play for checkmate here and
all of you should see the move Knight F6
check
and it's easy to conclude that this is
Checkmate but this is the point that I'm
making black has Knight D6 to F5
and that's it White's attack has fully
evaporated not only does black defense
G7 but he also tosses the queen out of
H6 you have to move the queen back
that's it black is up two pawns there's
no more attack you mean black can go
here
and you know the tables have turned
completely
so you might say well I see what I need
to do let's get rid of the Knight first
let's play Rook takes D6 that's I think
how most of your minds are working but
you have to look at this concretely you
can't just say oh I'm going to eliminate
the night and then it's going to work
because captures change circumstances
black takes back with the queen and
again we have a problem where we can't
go Knight F6 this time because black
simply takes twice and eliminates the
pawn you see what I'm saying you have to
look at it concretely so the solution to
the problem is actually a brilliant
quiet move notice also that the Knight
on D7 is actually hanging
and Bishop D4 fails for exactly the same
reason black as Knight F5
so you need to solve the underlying
problem of Knight F5 you need
prophylaxis you need a quiet move
it's not Bishop F4 that blunders the
Knight on D7
there's only one way to defend F5
and protect D7 and that is Bishop H3
it's the top engine move and it's the
only move that wins cleanly and I think
it's brilliant right to play such a move
in such a sharp position is incredibly
hard and once you put a Band-Aid over
the problem of the F5 Square the attack
succeeds immediately
because not only not only is white now
threatening Knight F6 check white has an
even simpler threat Wei in the game
plays Rook after d8
now Knight F6 check is actually not that
simple because black has a second
uh region from which he can defend G7
black is 98.
and white should be winning here after
Bishop F4 but the game continues so
instead Samuel finds a different mating
idea well what other mating techniques
are you familiar with when one side has
the Queen on H6 likes it think about it
well you've got Bishop D4 but then
there's again 98 not that convincing but
mombon Discord got it Rook to D4 ends
the game on the spot yeah very nice all
of you are getting at Rook D4 and wait
you resigned because after Rook H4 it's
Checkmate and two there's no way to stop
me
none
the only way to Stave it off is F5
but after Queen H7 King f8 The Quiet
move Queen takes G6 ends the game
because Rook h8 is now basically
Unstoppable
perhaps there's also Forest mate which
I'm blanking on let me see F5
yeah no I think this is this is the
simplest
this is the simplest Queen takes H7 and
queen takes G6
and everything everything
collapses here
so that is the beauty of understanding
these Concepts Bishop H3 is the only
move that wins the game cleanly
and to prove this to you
I'm going to turn on stockfish
maybe I'll be put to shame because I
last analyzed this game in 2017.
when it was played
maybe Stockbridge 15 changes its mind
but I don't think it will
there you have it Bishop H3 plus seven
Bishop H3 plus seven Rook fd8 Rook D4
Rook D7 Rook H4 here here Knight F7 Rook
to H7
and that's it black gets completely
massacred here is it the only winning
move Let's test that out
if we add variation it is look at this
the second best move is only plus 1.8
it's actually just to take the Rook
it's just a knight F6 check black is
basically winning that's the key
difference
uh
that's all there is to it okay
so off we go
to the game
a long way you know a a roundabout way
just to tell you how important it is to
never forget that Lobster pincer does
not necessarily mean Unstoppable me
okay
so Knight takes H7 here was winning and
it would have forced black to play Queen
takes D4 and give up an exchange in the
end game this is a pretty
straightforward technical Victory
because now we've got this Monster Pawn
on F6
that would have been the best way for
black to keep going after H5 Knight
takes C6 the game is totally over now
obviously there was no need for black to
play Queen takes F6 and blunder and
other exchange technically black should
play here but after Rook 81 or Rook a E1
whatever you want I'm not gonna talk
about this this is completely and
totally winning
okay so I think the decision to play
Knight F6 check and not to rush into it
with Queen H3 it really paid off
and we could have even played Rook takes
F6 here I think this would have also
been quite handily winning maybe even
better than he takes F6
and if black plays Knight t7
big deal just move the Rook back to F1
look at the dark squares on the king's
side the weakness of these squares is
totally decisive and if black plays
Knight takes C5
we use the technique I talked about in
the game Queen H3 Queen takes D4 and
Bishop E3 double attack against E3 and
H7
so multiple ways multiple rows lead to
Rome but I think we chose the one that
was most concrete and most safe and and
had a good compromise between still
being fun but not you know arbitrarily
giving away all of our advantages and
taking too many risks
yes I know the engine move is this
insane move Rook F6 but we're not going
to talk about it this is a ridiculous
move I don't even understand the idea of
it
but uh
yeah Knight F6 I think is
straightforward and very strong
any questions
[Music]